so we're here at the airport spotted
this cute cat
it's gotta be instagram famous it has to
be do you guys recognize this cat have
you seen have you seen him
hey guys so we're heading home for the
holidays and we're at the airport
jenna's here hey girl
we both brought the same book to read
josh sundquist we should hang out
sometime
it's like hey jen guess what i brought i
brought josh's sweaters that he sent us
guess what else i brought i brought the
book to read guess what jenna brought
same thing there's a cat over here and i
think
it's the cutest thing i've ever seen
i want to touch it
southwest decorations happy holidays
we're back in pittsburgh
on the previous flight on our way to
chicago we sat next to the kitty save
scene yep june she sat right next to us
okay but yeah when i'm next to you so
technically it was us
and my mom might have
gotten me an early christmas present and
i hope she'll let me open it because i'm
pumped when you're an adult i'm sure
shelf won't make you wait i hope mom
believe mommy please you just got home
from l.a we're in pittsburgh now my mom
and dad gave me my first little
christmas present early and i'm so
excited about this this is the new
nintendo 3ds it's the gamestop exclusive
edition
and it looks like a nintendo
nintendo entertainment system
yes
holy crap does it
look amazing
wow
it just makes me so sad the new 3ds is
not out yet but man this looks great
it is really nice check out this red
stylus
that'll be lost
this red styluses are easy to come by
yeah it's awesome i love it i'm so
excited
guess what time it is it's time to go
get our santa pictures taken and i think
this year for santa i'm gonna get uh i
think i'm gonna be playing my nintendo
and drinking a coffee what do you think
about that whatever you want to do
whatever i want to do what about you can
i do it i don't know but i can't take my
hat off because i haven't washed my hair
in two days and it's not nice
so what do i what do you want me to say
to that brie has the same sweater as
well
we match you guys do it's like
mother son
yes
we're doing our christmas shopping i
haven't yet sang holly jolly christmas
but i will later if you have an eye
blocks you can watch the lines we just
eat
it
holiday christmas photos have been
achieved
thanks free time i know we haven't still
accomplished anything okay so should we
get um what did we get she was running
into them first it's okay
children everywhere i'm one of them
and i was like
you and she was like watch you know us
parents really
we can't keep these young ones
yeah young ones me wait sephora finish
line oh my god our mom is so hard to buy
for we never know what to get her
mommy why
hey guess where we are at dicks oh wow
just sitting here at dicks sitting where
dicks oh look at you your safety time
i
have never left something as much as i
have it looks so good on camera wait
hold on
oh my god i'm all tied up
look how reflective
come closer
oh it's so reflective it looks nice oh
my goodness i feel like it should work
snap
burp and a e baiter
yeah okay all right how many people i
tell about that okay well right now
we're going into barnes noble we're
going to look for josh seung's book we
should hang out sometime it just came
out today depending upon when you watch
this video for when i post it where's it
at where's it at where's it at
barnes noble
new release new release it is red cover
look for red cover oh no
no no
josh josh nope i saw it close enough oh
great
oh it's a t-shirt and a mug okay
cool nope teach yourself taylor swift
is there a computer we could type into
red
nope
it's alfie's book too
it's alfie's book
okay
they're now on a hunt for the boss grace
grace holy moly it's like all my best
friends are here
russell brandon not my friend but if you
want to be my friend like i'm not going
to say you know what russell we can't be
friends but we can be
i i'm single now
well okay well
you just started hello
he did it's actually really funny
best friends best friends look at this
the whole family how many are here we
have ten ten should we get all of them i
don't know let's get wait let's see okay
everyone okay yes let's just take that
whole handful okay okay
uh i don't
want to sign up for today um it's okay
thank you
beau come here
go
you want to peek in the presents
no peeking
oh come here
oh
bo peeking in the presents
all right well a shopping day was
somewhat successful oh mommy we got we
got sienna pictures oh they're in my
purse merry christmas oh santa pictures
oh i see well the pictures i did not
wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
wait wait i want to see it
look at this guys really
it's our best santa pic really i'm
cheesing like a queen
i look so dumb
yeah that isn't that creepy yeah look at
me it looks
like a bow
oh
bubble wrap